Mike Pereira the former head of ahead of
NFL officials for many a moon and my
compadre of official review from NFL
Total Access on NFL Network back in the
day now listen with you all the time
give me a rule change give me a rule
Jane hey look I talked to you about the
Tuck rule you know how silly it was I
know I think I'm on to something here
with this catch rule Mike okay and I
understand it was appropriately
applauded yesterday I am NOT arguing
that at all okay why however if somebody
has possession of the football in their
hands and by trying to score puts the
ball in a spot they normally wouldn't
while trying to complete the catch why
are we penalizing somebody trying to
score why can't we make the change that
I'm supposing and proposing me down
which Jesse James had in the field to
play ball that's clearly in his hands by
merely reaching across the goal line we
should not penalize a player Mike
Pereira well lemon let me first go back
to the rule so I can put aside all the
people there killing me on social media
because I've heard all night long the
knee was down he reached out he lunge
into the end zone yes all of that which
are all true statements right and they
all apply to the receiver that's on his
feet so who's not going to the ground
apply totally control two feet element
of time there is no act that you can
perform on the way to the ground when
you're going to the ground that can
reverse it or make it a catch if in fact
the ball comes loose when you hit the
ground so they interpreted it right
great that is correct so I'm saying why
can't we now have the act of trying to
score being the rule change that you
said there is no act that can can of
that can negate the ground causing the
incomplete and I think if you do that
you bring in too much of the element of
gray you know how much is a real reach
how much is a Dez Bryant little reach I
mean when they brought all these X
players together you know to try that
come up with some solution it was
interesting Chris Carter a bunch
two receivers they all concluded that
the rule was okay the way it was because
it was more black and white than great
but yet it's a problem I grant you it's
a problem because if you look at a rule
and you and you think that wait a minute
Jesse James doesn't understand the rule
mike tomlin doesn't understand the rule
everybody that's watching is thinking
it's a catch and yet
replay reverses an official's decision
on the field to incomplete then it's
really to me not a good rule and you
know somebody said to me earlier today
and I've been popular today for the
first time in a while but somebody said
to me today back when you were on the
field in 1996 would this have stayed a
touchdown and the answer is yes why why
because there was no replay the problem
to me is replay has gone too far
we've gotten too technical in replay and
you're taking common-sense decisions
that are made on the field and you're
reversing them because the ball
momentarily moves to me this is a
judgment element of the game and doesn't
belong in instant replay and if we would
just leave the judgment calls into the
hands of the officials what did they
rule on Jesse James what they rule they
ruled it a touchdown because they all
look like a touchdown felt like a
touchdown smelled like it that's why
Lions fans who were listening to us
right now across the country saying
Golden Tate was the same damn thing
against the Atlanta Falcons and all of a
sudden now River on Buzz's in and says
well wait a minute me was here ball was
here arm was here not a touchdown and
that might be eventually over the next
two weeks the difference between Atlanta
going to the playoffs and the Lions
being home in the same way that this may
be the difference between Pittsburgh
having to go to New England or vice
versa for an AFC championship game so
how cuz I know you're you you have to
put things in words in black and white
what would you say to the competition
committee in terms of removing plays
like this from replay well I mean that's
what I would say let's get catch no
catch out of replay what would have
happened you think if we didn't have
replay over the play last night what do
you think would happen nothing Jim Jim
Jim Nantz Tony Romo they all
thought it was a touchdown when I saw it
the first time I thought it was a touch
so only when we slowed it down yes
technically it's a buy rule by the
technical application of the rule it's
an incomplete pass and I was texting
back and forth with Joe Buck last night
you know we had the I don't know if you
saw the butt cheek play in you know in
Carolina one cheek equals two feet you
know you don't need the whole pressed
ham on the to get that inbounds to have
it be a catch one cheek is good enough
are we becoming too technical let's get
in this game and making it hard to watch
through replay you know four stops in
the last quarter and a half last night
and the Raiders cowboy game I'm thinking
that we are I think Joe brings a good
point but I don't know how you actually
change the rule to say on your way to
the ground if you perform a football
move on the way to the ground then that
immediately makes it but he's clearly
reaching for the goal line
but if that's the if that is my prayer
if that is the way you put it in a rule
book to say this is the difference
between our catch in but in in between
the the ones and the catch that's going
from the one into the end zone if that
is the way that you could change it
because it does look like a catch now
yours you're saying just take catch not
a catch out of the replay basket which
is another fix on this front - yeah now
you know the other thing too is that
everybody points out which I understand
they say if a runner reaches out and
breaks the plane it's a touchdown
immediately correct but he's not a
runner he's not a runner yet cuz I get
it cuz he has not completed the process
on the catch my answer to that is though
is these guys are getting bigger
stronger faster more athletic the
process of the catch certainly in the
case of Dez Bryant was truly a 5-yard
span he's that big that strong that
athletic to be able to catch switch
hands and put it trying to get into the
goal line he should not be penalized
for that and we need to change the
rulebook based on how much bigger
stronger faster that we changed the
rulebook because we can't have the
goalposts at the front of the of the
endzone anymore I mean because times
change
athletes change athleticism is getting
more and more prevalent in this league
by guys at positions you wouldn't think
could make a play like Jesse James did
yesterday but I think when you already
have brought X players in and you've
already examined it from the top to the
bottom and they could come up with
nothing I don't think you're gonna get
the change you know I bring this up
George Young who I just loved George
Young when he was the head of football
operations and and I wrote about this
when he was there in 1999 we brought
instant replay back he didn't want it he
didn't want a period you know he
believed in the purity of the game and
he had a little manila folder right that
he kept his notes in because he was the
head of football operations and normally
when you think of a manila folder you
write on the tab you write instant
replay he wrote him big letters on the
front of the file the monster grows and
he's right and it's hard to back things
out but the games getting hard to watch
when they get so technical Mike I was
there at that first owners meeting of
the NFL network's existence down in in
Florida at the breakers at 2004 where it
was voted to be permanent or not and I
do remember a Mike Brown of the Bengals
voted no and and Al Davis abstain
because that's what he always did and
and everybody else said look if Joe or
Jane 6-pack is sitting at home with that
newfangled television they're putting on
a wall and can see it we should use it
too and one last thing before I take a
break and then we'll come back and we'll
talk about the other rule I want to have
changed that ended Sunday Night Football
and jeans territories new magical paper
card method of deciding the first downs
yeah when I said to you about the Tuck
rule we got to get it out and you were
defending the Tuck rule you did say to
me that the Tuck rule took more of the
gray area out of it and changing it
would put more gray back saying you you
have a disease
listen to me you remember everything
everybody says you just have too good a
memory you don't I'm not saying I'm just
staying but stick around right there
okay we're gonna come back and then
we're gonna take a break we'll come back
and talk about the Sunday night for you
got it Mike Pereira and also your phone
calls if you're on hold stay on hold
latavius Murray Aaron Donald Steve
Mariucci also on this busy Monday show
Indo Chino calm is something you need to
check out Mike Brewer certainly with you
sitting there in your stylish zip up
leather jacket I mean you you are you
got a ruler here today yeah with the
shoes you always you always are looking
your best you know it's in Pigalle
nervous look at you man Indo Chino is an
easy great way to get a suit made to
your exact measurements at a great price
you go to NGO Chino comm you visit a
showroom as well you can shop online and
get it any new Chino comm choose from
hundreds of top quality fabrics
customize whether you want to lapel
jacket lining monogrammed or more just
put in your customizations submit your
measurements place your order and wait
for it to arrive in just a few weeks any
premium Indo Chino suit can be gotten
right now for just 359 at Indo Chino
calm but you have to put my promo code
eyes in a checkout that's 50% off the
regular price for made-to-measure
premium suit plus shipping is free and
Oh Chi know calm promo code isin for any
premium suit for just three hundred
fifty nine dollars with free shipping
back with Mike prayer in a moment
Mike Pereira Fox rules analyst back here
for another segment on the show okay
let's get to the other windmill I'm
tilting at I hate this rule that you
fumbled the ball through the end zone
and the defense is the one that benefits
when you are a player like Derek Carr
game is on the line country is watching
ball out there had he fumbled it
directly to his right he gotten the ball
back had his opponent as one of his
teammates recovered it he would have
gotten the ball back had one of the
defenders knocked the ball out of bounds
he'd he gotten the ball back it just
rolled out of his hand rolls out of
bounds he doesn't get the ball back why
is the rule written the way it is Mike
Pereira III I think it's a difference to
me you know if you fumble the ball
forward and out of bounds in the field
to play it's different than putting a
loose ball into the end zone I do think
that's different and consistency wise
anytime you put the ball into the end
zone
you're basically it's either gonna be a
recovery by the defense or a touchback
but you put it in but yet I agree it's
probably too punitive and Kenny Fiore
that's a Byzantine nobody knows but
Kenny Fiore's worked at the league
office for a hundred years and every
competition committee meeting since 2000
he comes up and says this rule is a bad
rule and furious and and you know he
wants to change it I think it's
difficult because as I said I think it's
different when you fumble the ball
forward into the end zone well I'd like
why is it differ because you put the
ball you put a loose ball into your
opponent's endzone as opposed to out of
bound
but I think I'd be willing to listen to
a change but I think since it's more
it's more crucial when you put the ball
into your opponent's endzone I think you
have to come up with something different
than just giving the ball back to the
player at the fumble spot 10-yard
penalty for maybe somebody talks about a
reverse touch back put it at 220 I don't
I don't know but I think yeah I think
you get you know the kind of gimmicky
doing that but you know I look a session
entirely I mean that's to me that's
that's crazy talk that's crazy
I guess I understand that it that is
hallowed ground an end zone so it's
different between its signal lines okay
so I get that but
just the fact that game over or
possession over you know that's nuts man
you know so and you vers touch back to
me is a way to punitive somebody
suggested that this morning that I heard
and and they're not gonna go with
something like that you can't put a
fundamentally or tenure there's no you
can't put a penalty on a fumble it's not
an intentional and fumble it's one of
those that gets a lot of discussion but
III think again hallowed ground like you
talked about I know that we're all of
course I said you wouldn't get the tech
rule changed but you did tell me that
guess what happened and I just don't
think really because of the difference
of putting a loose ball into your
opponent's endzone as opposed to just
out of bounds in the field of play I
just don't think you're gonna make any
progress in there my prayer here on the
Rich Eisen show there is nothing in the
rulebook saying that you may use office
supplies determining a first down there
is nothing there is nothing so why did
he pull out a piece of paper he's an old
trick I've done it yeah oh yeah I did it
back when I was a referee in my college
days I've done it when you couldn't
really tell when it looks so close you
take a card out and you slip it right
down the front of that rod there and if
you touch the the ball when you slip it
down there at all then that means you
have reached the first down I think it's
interesting that starett or in his pool
report afterwards you know said that he
was just validating what he already
decided because he said that he had
already decided it was a first down so
then it becomes the starett or
entertainment show you know he wants
more face time you know by doing this
anything sir only got he certainly got
the conversation going on but you know
it's it's old school I mean I I I'm I
might have done it too he used his
everybody has a car he folded it over
because that's the card that you use to
track time outs and the penalties that
you call so you fold it over instead of
having one bigger sheet but he didn't
use fold first he went dying and if
somebody said what would you have used I
said by me I probably have my I probably
use my ARP card that's what I would have
to use if I was still on the field so
what is the rule though I mean if the
ball is
touching if the ball at all touches that
front rod there then it's a first down
okay and we all know by the way in exact
science I mean if you go back to how the
ball was first spotted on that sequence
you know it is an eye ball it is an eye
ball coming from the down judge who goes
to the sideline and goes okay put it
here so when it when it becomes then
that then it's an exact same but that's
part of the beauty of the game I know I
like that so in the two and a half
minutes I have left with you it works
kind of come full circle well you think
that replays gone too far and it needs
to be curtail back so I'd imagine you
don't think we should be using lasers or
or chips and footballs to try and you
know I mean you know already we've taken
the game off the field you know we took
the game out of the officials hands we
moved it to the replay booth now we've
moved it to New York and New York often
doesn't make the best decision you know
I know the more technology you're never
gonna make it perfect and people say we
need to put a chip in the ball so we can
see if it's a touchdown er well then you
need to put chip in the guy's knee in
the shin and everything because how are
you gonna tell when the knee is down so
you know we we have to understand that
no player plays the game perfectly I
have yet and I used to scour games when
I was in New York run on the program I
have yet to see a perfectly officiated
game replay or not I mean it's just this
drive for perfection isn't gonna happen
no matter what we try to do and I I
personally like the human part of the
game I like the game focused more on the
players and the coaches and the more
technology you bring in the more the
focus goes on officiating which keeps me
employed nice but I think it maybe makes
the game a little harder and then who
would be would be getting all the tito's
that you get and last minute I have to
go you're on the competition committee I
walk in with the Aisin rule of that the
goal line if you do have two hands on
the ball and you already have a knee
down or two feet down and play you
should not lose a touchdown by the
ground causing an incomplete pass
because you've reached across what
how does that go in that room do you
think that the room looks at you and
says rich you know I like the way you're
thinking and there are a couple plays
that are obvious but there are far more
plays that are not obvious and and we're
worried about getting to the gray area
even though Mike Pereira once told you
that the Tuck rule would never be
overturn because it would do it too much
great the gray area goes out is what I
said so I've got 15 seconds left what
about changing that rule with fumble
through the end zone not gonna happen
all right Mike prayer love you love you
coming on man thanks for coming or two I
know you're busy man just like out River
on no doubt is today latavius Murray
Aaron Donald the phone lines are lit our
number two and three beckoned for all of
us here on a busy Monday on the Rich
Eisen show the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on audience